Now I want to present you with three questions. I really want you to think
about this and discuss it with your peers on the forum. First, I want you to
think about how old your parents were when they got married, if they got
married. Now does this significantly differ from when you got married, or from
when you actually want to get married? Why yes or why no? Here’s the second
question. Why do you think there’s a shift in the age people get married? And
the last question. What are the main things that make you think that you are,
will be, or were ready to get married? So go to the forum and let’s talk about
this. I’m really excited to see what you guys say. I think this is going to be
a great discussion that we can have.